寝起きしていけばいいな
おはようございます多治見社長ですあの僕ちょいヘッド市 bar いうに来るんです
よどっちかというとね有名というか怖いですね後輩の市場がちょ家に来るんですけども
あもうすぐもうすぐ付けなご飯 a 2羽が今から言いに来るんですけどもう皆さんご
存知ずっとに僕がいまおかしいでジュース研修してます傾斜してるんでその
マジな方であの
本当だからねほんとだからねほんとに犯すジュース全く食べてないしなんでもないん
ですけどやっぱり裏で
飲んでいそうじゃないですか飲んでないけどね飲んでないよ飲んでないけど実際なんか
裏で飲んでそうだなってよく言われるんですけどもまぁ先とかいろんな後半にも見て
もらってるんですけど本当に飲んでないんですけども今からくる後輩ユーチューバーが
もし仮に僕が実はこっそりコーラを飲んでいたらどういう顔するのかっていうちょっと
検証していきたいと思います所準備しましたから残られぞれのんだ
ないからね実家にコーナー飲まずにこのいるまで近づけるかということまでしなきゃ
いけませんこくロンドンブラックコーヒーがある方で何かできそうだなと思ったんです
よねオキだ
テンション上げていこうバーッ
やべいってこんな色に近づけます飲んで沿って言われるんですよ実はコストに飲んでる
二種類や別注読んでるでしょいろんな人に言われるんですけど残すってないからそんな
つまらないことすると
ないねその時の音食べた時のリアクションの薄くなるからあれ設けかホラーシリーズの
ブラックコーヒーだけで結構良いですね行くんじゃないこれあー割といいって言ってる
なーおー
このえまって
本当に同じは公安と比べてかちょっとコインでちょっとクーンズを入れてわかんない
チョコれたんゼニスオイル的にほぼ完全に一緒ですよ
あの今回の見所食べたんですけどそんな僕コーラ飲んでるかを見た後の後輩の顔の表情
とかどんなカメラダーっていう曲見たくて行ってみようと思います
[音楽]
まずじゃねーこ
はいアーサーぜおっ
はい
い
[音楽]
ああなるんだぞ
はい
俺はなるほど
直せるた酸味料せずああーーてんっ
ていた
[音楽]
50分
はい
えっ
ゆる
異論は早い
はい
安全帯
なんで気づかないんじゃうわぁこれで企画デザインですよストア
なった事をいうべき
画像の味が普通に売ってるあれがとかという緑ですね
あ月末に変わるかするねー
五条西
を前世
どうです
何癖便利ですからまあ一日本1本くらいは軍隊なんだな
いい
女子ねぇてるしっ
えっ
え
a
[音楽]
晴れ
いやーいいいいとんちー離島についてやはりトーン4杯所行き
えっいてそ
[音楽]
ブーバーし
ano ano
いや近畿ですよ元気ですけど
バイト辞めてい中夫婦フェスとお金と時間に構ってるんだわかったみたいな
大丈夫を考える打たれて今防具
えっどう撮ってるんでそれそこ0
これこれえっ
me
あっ
ただ梅雨で今回の動画は外さざるコーナー乗っていたドッキリでしたーー
a どんなに入っ
たベニーイヤームーはまずと一瞬
いいでしまっていたああ俺頃のと思ったら一つっとみんなそういう